[Music]
and you my darling girl
are beautiful and i love you pink
dedicating her vma speech to
six-year-old daughter willow on sunday
night
singer performed a medley of her hits
before accepting the michael jackson
video vanguard award
with her daughter and husband in the
crowd she told a heartbreaking story
recently i was driving my daughter to
school
and she said to me out of the blue mama
say yes baby she said i'm the ugliest
girl i know
and i said huh
and she was like yeah i look like a boy
with long hair
pink said she made her little one a
powerpoint presentation of androgynous
rock stars that live their truth and
assured willow
she's dealt with similar criticism do
you see me growing my hair
she said no mama i said do you see me
changing my body
no mama do you see me changing the way i
present myself to the world no mama
do you see me selling out arenas all
over the world yes mama
okay it was with pink on the carpet
before that special moment
what does it mean to have her here
seeing you get this award everything
having my six-year-old girl in a
three-piece suit tonight and my husband
looking as dapper as ever
it's just a fun night i'm happy my
intention is to be the best mom that i
can be and also to have integrity and to
stand up for what's going on in the
world and
and that's why i'm right now couldn't
have come at a better time with what
about us out and i just
i feel really proud